Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Chaque minute qui passe,
5,9 millions de recherches
sont effectuées sur Google.
Vous et moi, on utilise
les moteurs de recherche au quotidien
pour nous informer, pour nous divertir,
ou encore pour savoir si le bureau
de poste est encore ouvert à 17 h 30.
Mais personne ne se demande
comment ça fonctionne.
On a tous pris l’habitude d’utiliser
Google, Bing, Qwant.
Pourtant, qui vous dit qu’un moteur
de recherche est pertinent et fiable ?
Est-ce que vous vous êtes
déjà posé la question :
« Ai-je déjà été manipulé
en faisant une recherche ? »
Alors j’ai la réponse et c’est : « Oui. »
Tous autant qu’on est,
on a tous été manipulés
par les moteurs de recherche.
On pense avoir le contrôle
de notre recherche.
Pourtant, c’est bien le moteur
qui décide pour nous
quels sont les résultats
qui sont pertinents.
Prenons un petit exemple.
Imaginons que, comme moi,
vous êtes nul en bricolage
et que vous avez besoin de faire
l’entretien de votre tondeuse à gazon.
Vous allez sur un moteur de recherche,
vous tapez par exemple
« vidange tondeuse à gazon »
et vous obtenez de magnifiques résultats.
Mais le problème,
c’est que les moteurs de recherche
vont vous afficher dix résultats.
Dix résultats ici,
parmi 1 170 000 résultats connus
sur les vidanges de tondeuse à gazon.
C’est le petit chiffre que vous voyez
et qui s’affiche juste
sous votre barre de recherche.
Et c’est ça, le cœur du problème.
Les moteurs de recherche
choisissent pour vous
les contenus qui sont censés
être pertinents.
Mais ils peuvent être inadaptés,
erronés, biaisés ou manipulés.
D’abord, il faut comprendre
comment ça fonctionne
Un moteur de recherche,
c’est ni plus ni moins
qu’un ordinateur, un logiciel,
qui a été conçu pour essayer
d’apporter une réponse à votre besoin.
Si je tape « vidange tondeuse à gazon »,
le moteur de recherche va essayer
de comprendre ce que j’ai tapé
et va essayer de me fournir des résultats.
Et si je dis essayer,
c’est vraiment important :
un moteur de recherche,
puisque c’est un logiciel,
ça ne peut pas comprendre
le sens des mots,
le sens d’un texte,
d’une image ou d’une vidéo.
Et d’ailleurs,
je ne leur jette pas la pierre.
C'est assez complexe.
Imaginez, vous prenez votre téléphone,
vous allez sur un moteur de recherche
et vous tapez le terme « kayak ».
Qu’est-ce que vous recherchez ?
Est-ce que vous recherchez le bateau ?
Est-ce que vous recherchez
la pratique sportive ?
le comparateur de voyage Kayak ?
Ou vous êtes fan de géographie
et vous cherchez l’île Kayak en Alaska ?
Le moteur de recherche
va faire exactement la même chose.
Il va essayer de comprendre.
Et vient là le premier problème :
il peut juste ne pas avoir compris
votre demande.
Et les résultats peuvent
ne pas du tout être adaptés.
Vous allez me dire, s’il n’y avait que ça,
ça n’est pas très grave,
ça pourrait passer.
Le problème,
c’est que les moteurs de recherche
peuvent être manipulés et biaisés
de plein d’autres façons.
Vous voyez, là, ça fait trois minutes
que je parle avec vous.
Je ferais bien une petite pause,
je prendrais un petit en-cas,
je mangerais bien une pizza aux anchois.
Alors je sais, j’ai des goûts bizarres,
mais essayons de faire le test ensemble.
Allons voir ce qu’un moteur de recherche
peut nous donner
sur une fameuse pizza aux anchois.
Alors faisons le test ensemble.
Pizza aux anchois.
Voilà les résultats de Google.
Si on allait voir un peu
les résultats par images ?
Allons dessus
et regardons un peu plus… tiens !
C’est quand même bizarre,
on a une pizza
un peu différente des autres.
Vous pouvez tous dire bonjour
à Adriana Karembeu.
Ça fait dix ans qu’elle est là.
Dix ans que le moteur de recherche
se trompe
et considère que Adriana Karembeu
est une pizza aux anchois.
(Rires)
Ici, on est dans le deuxième problème :
j’ai pris un cas extrême,
mais le moteur de recherche s’est trompé.
Il ne répond pas du tout à ma demande
et à cause de ça,
il peut m’induire en erreur.
Je pense ici que tout le monde
aura compris
que ce n’est pas une pizza aux anchois.
La vraie question est :
« Pourquoi est-ce qu’elle est là ? »
Pourquoi est-ce que le moteur de recherche
se trompe sur cette image ?
Pour la petite histoire,
un informaticien a fait un petit test,
il a pris la photo de Adriana Karembeu,
il l’a mise sur son site,
il a ajouté une petite description
marquée « pizza aux anchois ».
Et c'est tout.
Quand je vous dis
qu’un moteur de recherche
ne comprend pas le sens des mots
ou d’une image, c’est véridique.
Mais la vraie question à se poser, c’est :
si on peut manipuler comme ça le moteur
de recherche sur une image,
est-ce qu’on peut le faire
sur d’autres types de contenus ?
La réponse, là encore, est oui.
C’est même un métier,
on appelle ça le référencement naturel.
Sans entrer dans les détails,
le référencement naturel, ça consiste
à améliorer son site internet
pour prouver aux moteurs de recherche
que nos contenus
sont meilleurs que ceux des autres.
Mais personne ne peut vérifier
que nos contenus
sont réellement meilleurs.
Et pourtant, toutes les entreprises,
les associations, les organisations
ont besoin de référencement naturel.
Et donc dans certains cas,
ça peut poser une vraie problématique.
Un exemple concret :
l’été dernier, j’ai eu besoin d’acheter
un coffre de jardin.
J'avais besoin de ranger ma pelle,
ma pioche, mon râteau.
Je vais sur un moteur de recherche,
je tape « coffre de jardin »,
et là, je me rends compte
qu’il y a des dizaines et des dizaines
et des dizaines de références.
Donc je reformule ma recherche
et je tape « Avis coffre de jardin ».
Et alors là, j’ai eu de la chance,
je suis tombé sur le site de Nathalie.
Laissez-moi vous présenter Nathalie,
passionnée de coffres
de rangement et de jardin,
et elle en a testé
des dizaines dans sa vie.
Elle connaît les avantages
et les inconvénients de chacun
et comme n’importe qui qui a une passion,
elle a fait un petit blog
et elle partage son savoir.
Le souci, c'est que Nathalie n'existe pas.
Nathalie s’appelle sûrement Robert
et son but dans la vie,
c’est que j’achète ses produits.
Vous rentrez donc
dans une autre problématique :
la manipulation économique.
Et tout ceux d’entre vous ici
qui ont déjà acheté sur Internet,
vous avez probablement déjà été manipulés
par ce type de contenus
qui sont soit biaisés,
soit complètement faux.
Et d’ailleurs, dans certains cas,
on est même dans l’illégalité
avec des problématiques
de publicité mensongère.
Mais il y a encore pire.
Il y a des sujets dans notre vie
qui sont assez sensibles.
Vous savez, les thématiques
qu’on évite d’aborder le dimanche midi
en repas de famille.
Des thématiques comme la sexualité,
la religion, la politique
ou la réforme des retraites.
Ces sujets-là,
ils font partie de notre vie.
Et donc nous, internautes,
on va forcément,
tôt ou tard,
faire des recherches sur ces sujets.
Et donc le moteur de recherche
peut potentiellement nous influencer.
En 2018, par exemple, aux États-Unis,
si vous tapiez le terme « idiot »,
voici ce que le moteur de recherche
vous montrait :
des dizaines de photos de Donald Trump.
Loin de moi l’envie de juger
des capacités intellectuelles
de l’ancien président américain,
mais le simple fait
qu’un moteur de recherche
puisse me présenter ce type de résultats
en plein milieu
d’élections présidentielles
peut potentiellement influencer ma vision
de cette personnalité politique.
D'ailleurs, au début des années 2010,
des chercheurs ont fait des tests.
Ils ont pris différentes élections,
ils ont pris des personnes indécises
et ils leur ont présenté des résultats
qui étaient faussés
et qui favorisaient un candidat
plutôt qu’un autre.
Dans certaines de ces études,
jusqu’à 48% des indécis
avaient changé d’avis
pour l'élection concernée.
Ça veut dire qu’aujourd’hui,
dans cette salle, la moitié d’entre vous
aurait pu être influencée
en faisant une recherche sur un moteur.
Et donc là, on est dans une manipulation
intellectuelle et politique
qui est beaucoup plus problématique
dans notre vie quotidienne.
Mais on peut faire encore pire.
Il faut savoir que mes recherches
ne sont absolument pas les vôtres.
Pour une raison qui est simple :
une grande majorité des
moteurs de recherche qu’on utilise
personnalisent les résultats.
Ils peuvent le faire selon votre langue,
selon votre historique de recherche
ou encore selon votre géolocalisation.
Dans certains cas, ça a eu du bon.
Par exemple, il y a un mois,
j’ai eu le bonheur et la joie
de tomber en panne.
Donc comme n’importe qui, je prends
mon téléphone, je tape « dépanneuse »,
et comme j’habite à Nantes,
j’ai des dépanneuses
de la région nantaise.
Si ce soir, en sortant de cette salle,
je tombe en panne,
je refais la même recherche,
j’aurai des dépanneuses à Lannion.
Là, c’est une bonne chose.
Le souci, c’est que toutes les recherches
peuvent être personnalisées
selon différents critères.
Prenons une thématique
qui n'a rien à voir.
Prenons l'histoire récente de la Chine.
Vous connaissez peut-être
la place Tian’anmen.
Une place où, en 1989,
des événements assez sanglants ont eu lieu
avec des manifestations
qui ont été réprimées par le régime.
Si je vais sur un moteur de recherche et
que je tape place Tian’anmen en français,
la page de résultats qui va s’afficher
me montrera à la fois
des résultats liés au lieu
et à la fois des résultats
liés aux manifestations
dont je viens de vous parler.
Maintenant, je refais la même recherche
et je change juste ma langue.
Je passe en chinois.
Je pars du principe que tout le monde
sait parler et lire du chinois.
Mais cette page de résultats
a complètement occulté
les événements de 1989
et ne parle que du lieu.
On est donc dans une manipulation purement
et simplement historique des faits
et qui donc peut tout simplement
changer ma vision des choses.
On pourrait se dire :
« Mais que fait la police ? »
En France, on a plusieurs organismes
qui sont censés nous protéger.
Je peux en citer deux, par exemple
la CNIL ou la DGCCRF.
Il y en a d'autres, bien entendu.
En 2022, ces deux organismes,
c’était environ 3 000 agents.
3000 agents pour contrôler tous les sites
et les entreprises françaises.
Sauf que depuis que je vous parle,
ça fait environ onze minutes,
quasiment 70 millions de recherches
ont été effectuées
sur le moteur de recherche Google.
3 000 agents
face à 70 millions de recherches.
Elles n’ont absolument pas les moyens
humains, financiers et techniques
de contrôler l’ensemble
des contenus sur le web.
Et dites-vous bien que les moteurs
de recherche, c’est pareil.
Que ce soit Google, Qwant,
Bing ou un autre,
ils ne peuvent pas contrôler en temps réel
les contenus qu'ils proposent
aux internautes.
Sinon, je n'aurais pas retrouvé
ma fameuse pizza aux anchois.
Et donc les moteurs de recherche
posent beaucoup de problématiques.
Si on reprend le cheminement :
j’ai été manipulé d’abord
tout simplement parce que le moteur
de recherche n’a pas compris
ce que je désirais en tapant « kayak ».
Il s’est trompé lourdement
quand j’ai voulu manger
une délicieuse pizza aux anchois.
Il m’a manipulé économiquement
en voulant me faire acheter
un coffre de jardin plutôt qu’un autre.
J'ai été manipulé politiquement en
considérant Donald Trump comme un idiot
et j’ai été manipulé historiquement
avec l’histoire récente de la Chine.
Donc aujourd’hui,
qu’est-ce qu’on peut faire ?
Qu’est-ce que chacun de nous peut faire
pour éviter d’être manipulé
ou d’être biaisé de cette façon ?
J’ai plusieurs conseils,
ils sont très simples,
que vous pourrez appliquer
dès que vous allez faire
de nouvelles recherches.
Mon premier conseil est très simple :
consultez toujours plusieurs résultats.
Quand vous faites une recherche,
ne vous arrêtez pas à un contenu,
allez en consulter plusieurs.
N’hésitez pas à aller
en page 2 d’un moteur de recherche.
Plein de contenus vous y attendent
et qui sont tout aussi pertinents.
Deuxième conseil qui est très simple :
reformulez votre recherche.
Si vous reformulez votre besoin,
le moteur de recherche va y répondre
de manière différente.
Troisième conseil :
testez un autre moteur de recherche.
En France, vous avez Google
qui a une part de marché ultra dominante,
mais vous pourriez tester Yandex, Ecosia,
DuckDuckGo, Qwant, Bing et plein d’autres.
Et surtout le conseil le plus important :
quand vous allez cliquer sur un résultat,
demandez-vous toujours
qui a écrit le contenu,
quelles sont ses sources,
et surtout quelles sont ses intentions.
Et en appliquant
l’ensemble de ces conseils,
vous allez prendre du recul
sur les résultats d’un moteur de recherche
et donc vous allez réduire
les manipulations potentielles.
À titre personnel, je reste persuadé
que les moteurs de recherche sont un outil
à la fois puissant, formidable,
utile au quotidien,
et que ça va durer des années.
Que ce soit pour vous informer,
pour découvrir une nouvelle passion,
pour acheter un produit
ou pour réparer votre lave-linge.
Mais c’est un outil puissant,
à la seule condition de savoir
que cet outil peut être biaisé,
erroné, inadapté ou manipulé.
Donc la prochaine fois
que vous ferez une recherche,
posez-vous toujours la question suivante :
« Puis-je faire confiance
à ces résultats ? »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)